hi
thank your caller Thanks getting right
into the game heroes never die someone
mentioned it looks like herpes never die
no no one said that I would not have
noticed if you didn't say it yourself
Shaw Shaw said that and it ruined my day
for people who don't know that's a
former game spot producer and he's also
worked in twitch and he's not my friend
look at this look at this stuff alright
so we they are just gonna keep flaming
this dude until someone tells me
something else to do we we've been
talking in the comments and on the show
lately about whether we are going to
play Chris sorry Jake and Sherry's
campaign we're gonna leave that as like
one of the bonus ones and just get right
to 7:00 after this is done people seem
to be in agreement that we should just
go hike it's invisible
alfe at HQ we're engaging remember the
name of the snake from here's Marco hold
on me we're going after that thing
Rodrigo yarn Johann that's a better name
you're close though
see I see the connection you made you
can see my train of thought there are
you thinking of Carlos from resident 3 I
think
I think I was thinking of sandlot for
some reason and Rodriguez popped up and
I was like no that's not him whose boat
was just a game Benjamin Franklin
Rodriguez this was lying why do you need
two people to open a gate that's already
open listen don't think too much about I
don't even need to open it they could
both squeeze through there I'll be less
than negative for the rest of the
episode right I went to I went to wine
country with my mom and she told me I
wasn't allowed to be so sarcastic
anymore because every time someone was
like this was a good year I'm like yeah
it was even sarcasm well that's sarcasm
sorry but it's more like mocking I mean
it's it's more than sarcasm this is a
good oh yeah this hasn't oaky afterbirth
you can tell that it this is a really
good man that's a that's a wine good
yeah I know it's got a lot of hops to it
you drank a whole bottle of whiskey that
you brought in get out of here that wine
oh you okay ma'am this is not wine and
also you just stop it stop bring in
machetes to a knife fight you're gonna
look like a fool kill him
oh I brought a knife to an arm fight so
weird saying yeah well it was inspired
by this game this game is inspiring I
just want to like get to the good stuff
and I realized that we started this a
year ago right really more than a year
this is the anniversary because I told
you the anniversary because I got a ping
about it on Facebook that's right yeah
but I know that we should have fun so we
got it okay so this is actually kind of
a big deal right I think it's good
timing because we're starting resin evil
seven during October like Halloween
month right cool good time maybe we'll
wear costumes but they're in one of the
episodes that would be cool I don't have
promise anything but I promise we'll
wear costumes well we do need to do a
turn soon because just so people who
watch this series regularly know I have
to go to twitchcon and then I
immediately go to pax Australia so I'm
gonna be like oh [ __ ] I can't use my
knife in the scenario
so I can't be here as much as I would
like to
so I really need to even a game audio a
little lower than usual because people
are saying our voices sounded low last
episode anyway yeah I'm gonna be gone
for three weeks and I think we need to
turn before them so you let me know
[ __ ] you're gross yes if you see three
little balls they got little balls in
the back people are recommending that we
use those points to do item drop they
increase that because then we won't have
as much ammo scarcity that's smart
that's good cuz usually we just get home
and we get those points oh I do get
pissed when I get those points because I
feel like it hasn't been hasn't hasn't
actually given me much help in the game
I guess I guess their point is that we
bad things we're gonna damage an item
drop so then you use less ammo and you
get more ammo are you hot in here it's
so hot I just get this
most sweaty Chris yeah but he glows
remember back when we used to actually
care about cutscenes in the show yes hey
we're not gonna play your campaign
idiots what I don't care how hard you
try have you seen me up with them again
yeah cuz it's cheryan
sherry and uh Jake teamed up with Leon
and Elena already wobble-bottom where
are our our paths crossed I'm very
awesome
is he always I was almost said that was
Michael but he's not outside
that's a Mikey imposter honestly use did
you yes no I just like there's a ladder
right next to me and instead I just
jumped up I'm gonna be honest with you I
don't know if there's a lot to do with
hey that is a Chihuahua Chihuahua
what are these objective markers
pointing at the cherry and Jake I guess
I guess I'm just shooting the helicopter
oh there's Java on the side of it okay
on the side of the helicopter there was
an account amount I'm just shooting the
pilot right now I don't know that was
supposed to be okay
oh my god can I shoot this person or are
those my people carrier down there I'm
gonna help them a little boy Oh what the
[ __ ]
what yeah he's on the side I was talking
about that mantis man yeah mantis
toboggan MD whoa whoa whoa I'm being
shot if you need ammo down here where I
am right now there is l1 see if that
tell I'm not so concerned just says help
sherry and cake I mean maybe they're
supposed to help me you coward
mantis toboggan is [ __ ] me up alright
okay so it says the objective right now
is help Sheree so I'm just shooting the
soldiers well I guess I said
whoa
oh you got it slugging stabbed in the
back yes oh [ __ ]
all right oh there's a lot of stuff
going on over here getting shot from a
helicopter guy with a knife all we need
is Mike me I could use a mic like who's
shooting at me right now
stop moving
can we go down there we have to set here
I don't know I don't feel very confident
I don't think I've even shot this guy
yet I'm working on it
look I might have a little sweet that's
perfect yeah well put some points into
it oh [ __ ] are you down no I don't think
so
oh just okay so we just shooting the
dudes on the side of a helicopter but I
don't have any ammo damn it I'm coming
oh there's you're just killing all these
guys yeah I need your dispute cover kill
all those man T what's the plural of
mantas man ty it depends on if it's
Greek or Latin Latin would be man 2 no I
think it's Greek you actually change the
instant to I Greek or Latin I don't know
it's gonna wanna talk about it clearly
trying to sound smart I guess there's a
lot of man to hear and they're ugly
sorry to kill those red diamonds you got
it
they're slow and dumb but boy can they
make a mean pie you just tried to claw
me with his tooth like a raptor like an
ostrich what did we lose yeah I get it
there's a lot of unknowns in this game
Wyatt what am I doing here
what is my purpose seriously have you
seen that that's a really old Derrick
comedy like Donald Glover before he's
childish gambino in on community you did
a skit no I'm not even gonna acknowledge
that and I'm just gonna make it seem
like you've never seen your own dick
alright cuz that's a funnier reality
okay what do they look like Mike kind of
like you don't know I try angular yeah
it's my guess a little bit like it's
like like Kevlar or no have you seen a
good fellas like that fan
grenade-launcher a tube bag of sand bags
of Sam that bag I cut up yours got a
grenade launcher now though I'm assuming
we're nuts chopper down and bring it
down hard hang it down hard oh yeah
I'm just gonna hit it with your name on
it
I'm [ __ ] it up I'm just gonna throw
all these
I'm getting [ __ ] up a lot of gonna you
kill you kill the zombo's and I'll hit
the tombow
you know I won't bow you oh [ __ ] shiri
one bow one bow
I'm [ __ ] up sorry nah it's all good
just stab through your pull it through
best somehow what have you prick listen
I don't have a new life down
that's the explosion that we just saw no
of course not why would people damn it
whoo [ __ ] I need [ __ ]
listen I'm down all right well I'm
definitely down really wet
I got machete while I was trying to eat
a pill I'm dead
well the the silver lining is that all
this occurred because I was trying to
have enough room in my hold on what's
been torched those herbs right now I've
to read herbs no I have five pills oh my
god I'm just going sorry in the chopper
I'll be up there
I'll see you you know what on the ear
see you on the other sail
[Music]
[ __ ] this guy all right so the zoms
gazhams are out in full force I figured
it out good hell are you
it's been back they have too many of
these goddamn grenades
coming out how do you take cover again X
all right
this isn't even a grenade launcher it's
a rocket launcher they go straight into
the horizon and then art like after a
mile uh-huh no I don't know why I'm
surprised with the students military
exercise ship
whoa I got [ __ ] rocketed in the dome
yeah wait we did it I shot it like 25
times the grenade launcher you're
amazing thank you I killed one mantis
mentis toboggans
he dropped his monster condom to show
off his Magnum dong hi hey it's your
best friend
he was Hawk salute god damn you're
awesome but are you always this way
going after that often
yes yes probably but she definitely is
gonna get away with that that's her
thing is getting away with things she's
known for it it was her minor in college
those are majors engaged in each walk
he's dead
[Music]
what happened what's no way to go out
what happened to him is he just dead he
said that he like has no head or ism
this is Santa hat over here like I saw a
guy get killed by an invisible snake and
you think that's gonna come here quick
jolts me is this a Santa hat hold on I'm
on my way somebody's playing backgammon
back here look at next to the TV oh just
Santa hat or at least om Blum where a
pillow should be that's weird what here
oh good job something weird there's a
box in here I think it is I think it's a
point a stocking maybe because this is
Christmas stuff maybe I don't know
[Music]
there's a moan here or points for me oh
cool coming oh [ __ ] it's ammo and I
can't take any of it just put combine
your red and green and put those in your
infinity that's smart
he's smart
god you're smart would you show yourself
you're invisible circle it's using its
invisibility against us sir if an
ostrich could fly it would never come
down why am i aiming what the [ __ ] is it
making you automatically aim - yes
oh my god he's dead
it would be pretty cool if your last
name was awesome Hollywood names these
are my men you follow my leader I'll
find someone who will do you even hear
yourself yes I want to I want to meet
the voice actor for Chris Redfield how
many people have said you're awesome how
many little prick I won't meet the voice
actor for Chris Redfield I bet you've
never seen a dick in your life go out
with him let's buy him a drink and then
when he's about to drink it splash it in
his face shut up and keep moving damn
chris is just unraveling and by that I
mean you are hey I appears you should be
armed I'm drunk on power do not start a
coup with me in the room it's a mutiny I
will end you do I look weird am i doing
the right thing I went the wrong way
I'm the captain don't go with help me I
am the captain Oh No all these dead
dudes no wait I bet you they're gonna
say there's a bad way to go he did that
was Chris
these giant snake wounds indicate that
he was killed by gunfire maybe why does
it keep doing that
it means the cutscenes coming up
so can I kill these rats come on out you
rats
okay I'm going are you okay sir oh my
god this snake was making drugs he just
got a balloon full of coke up its butt
he was mewling them too he's got he's
doing the whole aberration himself I
don't need your help I could use the
most game of fied game we find any much
that onto one of their allies just
smushes someone is that one of us no I'm
running out of solder it's not like a
giant snake is gonna like here I'll meet
you on the second phone don't be late
bring a cigar Oh - oh yeah he's dead
damn it
Chris Shaw all of my faithful men are
dead and I'm just stuck with one
insubordinate son of a [ __ ] Marc origin
America oh [ __ ] I think I just got hit
by it
no way yeah well it sounds like it'll be
really cool for everyone to see my spin
I've been bit Yogesh Marcus I just got
bit by a love bath peers
door peers peers hey hurry up hurry up
for being like Oh dentures and in
busines
sit down no you just hear my react they
come up to me composer don't hear my
reaction again was it jerk yeah Jeb is
that he said all right circle let me see
if I have one too I think you already
looked at him then you have to God we're
cool get off its hinges captain awesome
to you soldier
where are you son of a [ __ ] the
basilisk Chris things need to parse
Antonio's like this I bet one of these
pigs is the snake its saliva I will not
lose another unnamed soldier to this why
would they wait like are we talking to
him yeah hey Chris the Parseltongue
things could get hairy oh I see him
[Music]
I hear there's um there's a little hidey
nook under here do you want to go under
it there's right here
hey wise well there's a hallway over
here too okay I'll take this back up
you're [ __ ] up use a grenade launcher
in there yeah he's in the hallway let's
go oh god you scared the [ __ ] out of me
if I can use the grenade launcher to
tube yeah
regret it don't you oh here he is
furious
you killed my man he ate my bird any
funny if I could go back and this was
like the snake was related to Yanni like
you killed my brother
Mike do you think he's in the hole I bet
he's in the hole oh you're here he's
right here no he's not he'll be in a
hole six feet underground when we're
done with him I hear him samesies there
you are going into the hole oh honey
well I've already committed to the hole
so I'm gonna go in it
oh hi baby listen even you should heal
that's an order captain
that's captain awesome to you soldier
that's an order captain awesome thank
you [ __ ] is this thing so I stopped
going in there I feel vulnerable you are
vulnerable my ass should feel vulnerable
where's that where's our other yeah what
is this [ __ ] useless piece of [ __ ]
doing he's scared he's I'm scared too it
what's that quote about bravery being
scared and then doing it anyway good no
that's just my sex life thank all right
I'm going in the hole again stop going
in there get out of that goddamn well
I'm coming in there with you hey crab
hey okay let's keep going to the other
end see if this yields any fruit
right look look this way Sony NEX my
spot yeah you do please follow us the
whole way down grows behind you behind
you
no I'm just kidding the music would give
it away
cuz that's the kind of game oh I'm
coming you better come idiot it's a [ __ ]
get up
oh my god are you dead no okay
can't keep ears down okay you went back
into the hole what the [ __ ] what I'm not
going back in there well the holes
broken luckily are useless soldiers
politie I used I used a rocket again
yeah I really don't want to revive you
right now why cuz you just blew us up
wasn't you up no no no it's gone you
know I'm gonna use this rocket
oh [ __ ] did you what I killed us both
okay I just slept like a bunch of pills
I wouldn't have done that
well now I'm like super high cool what
did he was so shaky I can't really like
oh my god Robin noodles oh here here
serious serious [ __ ] yous coming
why don't you think checkpoints when I
get wrapped up that's how the game works
oh no I did it yet he's a snake they
have them million lives
oh yeah of course about him
now suddenly for some reason I remember
what a penis looks like it's oval and
it's got a big hole in it
oh that sucks sound like you deserve to
die or anything
did we lose our only friend he's somehow
fine he's just a little bit digested
it's my first day sir
really excited hope I don't get eaten by
anything
I have no prejudices I don't care what
it is that eats me I would you prefer it
not to know i looked way less than
heroic there oh no our friends wait
we're relying on one of these npcs we're
gonna have to run what we do it static
electricity
stop hitting me I'm gonna go up to that
lever rocket straight up murder you in
real life okay he's coming this way go
up the ladder oh my god he's coming he
is right behind me and my help slow
because you use that piece of [ __ ]
grenade launcher you need me to use a
rocket no good timing
Thanks [ __ ] I need to go over there I
was gonna die Marko's [ __ ] go over
there Oh what are the odds that he
survives uh Scott seemed like to pursue
what a idiot all right there's an herb
over here also and I'm gonna all right
I'm you say over here I've got a lot of
health actually now know what's up
[ __ ] I'm down here oh I think I have to
go over there and reconnect it oh oh
maybe not yeah I'm fairly certain I do
so little I understand about this vibe
but how do I don't press that again yet
don't do that I'm not AG do it now yeah
gotcha electrocuted that other snake and
I read evil three I do remember that is
it done there's no way is it yeah suck
static Oh Chris I always admired you
let's get to our friends yeah mark oh
you weren't that usual but I want to
save him he's just gonna lift us up yeah
feel like that water should still be a
lot today how did you get up mark I'll
pull me up oh [ __ ] I shall execute my
tables table oh this guy's pretty cool I
like this guy come here a second oh
there's a red plant here there's a am on
the other side of this hose thing if you
jump it
[Music]
over here do you jump over that hose ha
ha ha just getting good do you miss all
right hey rest until we know that other
guy no no that's captain awesome
how many times I said wow that dude just
tripped behind you I'm not kidding I
don't know why I have that stumble
animations to show him that he's afraid
it's just a de 80 Wong Wong show
yourself
she's the real snake I never pull out
like Dennis she's hot we just went
through so much [ __ ] to save that guy
for us Chris
you suck in this game
bees no not the bees we can't shoot
individual bees oh great all I have is
never had one left perfect Oh Shh what
the [ __ ] this game of thrones sanest
makes that phantom got it damn oh wait
was that Finn no he just always had the
explosive so I associated I'll get it
this must be c4 or something punches
Ash's use no need to punch his ashes
this is biceps for the size of my thighs
Markos see forest
yes oh wait Hollen there's ammo right
there he does everything so he punches
everything now they have been farther
away and also they probably could have
kicked it open like the last one oh my
man they called after what she's done to
us how many of our men are dead because
of that badge I'm right there with you
captain I your personal vendetta isn't
gonna get us anywhere if you hadn't been
blinded by vengeance we could have
prevented some of those deaths oh do you
even care about our mission
[Music]
yeah you're not as awesome as you think
you are they start making alright now
that would make sense just licking each
other's wounds yes I need a location I
need a wand I hate you but god damn it
do I respect you expect to always see me
just two steps behind them sweet man one
of the arms you're all glamour muscles
you could not scale the facade of
Citizens Bank
there's too many sunny deep cuts in this
episode there's a lot coming from you at
all times this time a night covered in
Bo W I'm not in the I brought Lunchables
y'all sure got like another 15 minutes I
would say
until this game is over
another game because episode I would say
let it be known that I'm a nice person
and brought Lunchables oh sure there's
snipers of course there are
during lunchable time you know hey
there's still a game happening gotta eat
why is he not what is happening all
right listen
a sniper might be shooting at me killed
I killed the snipers
I also shot people okay now I'm gonna
have some turkey and Swiss just don't
eat in the mic listen someone I'm the
last episode called out my muse the
phony on Oh Matt boom mantises there's
mantises coming it was awkward because I
climb over that yeah going that way
Bok Bok
these [ __ ] snipers sniping Manti yeah
oh you've decided it's Manti okay this
[ __ ] oh yeah sniped Sokka my
perfectly shaped ass Oh ever need longer
moments I would say listen there's a lot
of red lasers on my babe activate the
lasers oh [ __ ] that's ridiculous
for a mantis he's a hell of a shot
horribly ugly but man is he a marksman
that's why they keep him around where am
I going now
I don't know where I'm okay it's you hey
over this my family I'm not even gonna
worry about that guys let's just go okay
all right that one I just I actually
need some some believe that I believe
that you got him you're mad cuz I got
bullies you need those full bones huh
you know what this is a good time for
it's a rocket launcher I just yeah just
use mine against those Manti manti te'o
football player right yeah
yeah you made headlines a little while
ago I don't remember yeah Oh lunchable
you got ham and cheddar I got ham and
Swiss cheddar all day son you know pop
that Chetty yo Chetty head what up son
yo Mike the Chet head
Nivens hey run
like should it hide
that's evil Mikey
no we're serious my I agree
that looked really funny from my point
of view didn't look great from my point
of view you stop point blank shot I got
the grenade launchers dead no get the
[ __ ] out of my way
nothing says move like a [ __ ] grenade
to the pelvis where is he you just
replace his stomach with a grenade I got
it Galloway okay we're gonna come up on
a boss fight and you're not gonna have
anything what a [ __ ] how pop that shed
I was so far back
don't talk just what tell me what you
not talk about [ __ ] rude
you're the one who said don't talk oh
I'm sorry captain you just arguing with
yourself
those were captain's do I think you're
gonna die no I dodged it
got him
got him
I got a knife [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
we should keep going
you should stop dying as well listen pop
that cheddar for a second it's Swiss you
just said it was Hammond it says Hannah
cheddar
yours is cheddar mine Swiss I'm a Swiss
Miss better be cheddar I run I run just
keep running this time I think the
mistake is is that I'm stopping to shoot
someone yeah I don't think he knows fine
then I'm not gonna stop this time I'm
all in on the running and Swiss cheese
which is better than cheddar no scarf
that Swiss son
it's a big secret sign
yeah I just keep running honestly don't
hit me oh yeah it was a good call turns
out you know it's a gong what a schlong
show that's how you know when you're
actually like no joke
what do you mean I don't remember the
gong every time you kill people to take
a bow oh right yeah I do I do you play
for yeah you like it
that's all right people got pissed
because I gave it a 7 I think it's
totally a 7 for whatever that means to
people for you that means it's a good
game that I enjoyed I think it's a good
game I don't think it's a great game you
know there was a time if you remember
this when you were like scaling a giant
cavernous wall and it's just such a long
scene oh [ __ ] oh these must be shooting
him I think yeah yeah shoot down the
helicopter pretty clear wow I have a lot
of grenades hey hold up back up back up
back up back up check this out okay let
him walk in okay
that not killing [ __ ] is this okay god I
hate helicopters so much Mikey in which
case I love them how is he Papa quick
chief a girl is better with some cheddar
let's go
that's that stupid game let's be hard
right floaties Renea launchers and
machetes it's like all we are you go I
found trunk jab how much longer do you
think the game is I don't know this is
chapter 3 I don't even know how many
there are
I think we're about to finish chapter 3
I feel like there's got to be more than
three chapters
I feel like six is normal yeah which
means we're not even close that we're
close I'd say uh we can call the episode
they're actually probably you think 45
minutes a little more God do more than
that if you want beat those we'll beat
it I just cancel this this is coming up
on a big fight I'm assuming if it's
let's do the fight alright I think this
is where they've been developing the C
virus you're not yourself when you're
yeah what tipped you off said Medical
Research Center [ __ ] prick I'm not
that angry I just hate piers
a very captain of you
thanks for the Lunchables I'm not the
captain you are there's not enough
cheese for the Lunchables you know that
there is like a whole block of cheese
she's like literally really good at
hiding Leon and Hellena run hey there
there what was I supposed to do she run
her mouth oh this [ __ ] again Mary what
the [ __ ] laughs why you can't either
because you're going down
[ __ ]
how do I disable it I'm getting [ __ ]
up here hey it's a real Italian gal why
it won't this break
oh we just couldn't do it before then I
got it heal up in tears hey I'm gonna
heal and you want some of this
sure thank you
I was a weird camera angle like it was
reminiscent of the old games but good
job no I liked it huh
it's just weird who's like happening out
of nowhere like they didn't do it they
didn't do it anywhere else
intergalactic cinematic what the hell is
all this
it's a deaf chamber table Jesus really
into the B word like go easy with your
words there man
says the says the guy who is just saying
[ __ ] prick
yeah nah kind of Chris that will help
hey yo Dion we got cheddar let us in we
brought lunch above get that hot
Lunchables actually pop that cheddar
come on Jesus defend me while I open
this door a little bag of tricks isn't
going to stop us oh [ __ ] it up dump
quick time event got it
hey RC ugly uh maybe you should pull
your own weight I got to do it again can
you protect me [ __ ] I hate this I feel I
get their minds and I'm shooting them
that shouldn't help the situation
alright did another one got a three more
two more watch out haha [ __ ] go go
ada your cleavage is very out there
whatever not saying it's I have no
opinion either way but show ass I don't
have an opinion either way but ADA that
you look great in that dress
dare we tell you when I was a waitress
once one of the dudes that was also a
waiter with me came in the back and was
like I'm waiting on these two people
that are having a date and the girls
nipple is prevalent enough where I can
see it and I don't feel comfortable
telling her for sure out know it's out
like her nipple was out of her shirt and
her boyfriend wasn't saying anything and
he didn't want to say anything and he
was like all right if I was her
boyfriend I was at hey maybe her
boyfriend like couldn't see it or
whatever but it was like super confusing
or maybe he made her do it and we were
arguing about what should happen and
then the fish like the dishwasher was
just like hey I just helped you out for
a second if that was me in that
situation I would just say ma'am yo
titty is hanging out yeah and we were
like yeah it's pretty good advice I
don't like to only told her though but I
wish you done here actually
ma'am yo titty
you know what son right here hanging out
this next episode wait wait did you get
a we get a save after this we should
let's do this let's open up next episode
of this God you seen this before as long
as we get a cutscene or like a I feel
like this is the end like this is the
[ __ ] end I remember this my only fear
is that there's a boss fight no this is
the end this is the end of this no cuz
remember she gets away yeah this is the
end of this but it's not the end of like
Chris and here's thing oh well let's
let's finish this part up because I know
she like tries to get away no no we're
recording this on a Friday after evening
and not trying to cut it short I'm
having fun with the game not you uh-huh
put your gun down Leon you put your gun
down you put your gun down can they both
be fo can they both be equally [ __ ] yeah
she's working for
you know what that means yeah and you're
still going to protect this woman
just shooting on the face Chris
there's a long standoff
so consistently sneaky zip zip Zuri Boas
that's my catchphrase
Zuri and a zip zip Cerebus I'd rather
listen to this cutscene
[Music]
so she says right before she kills
someone zip zip sorry boys current
sequence this will be fun to start next
up they were right I'm super Heidi why
is he in a good mood all this I love you
Leon said muscles have some pretty
profound
for him to change attitudes like that
give us a freaking alright does that
mean saving feel like that means loading
peers Nivens spoilers alright we'll see
you next week and I'm a Resident Evil 6
going crazy thank you everybody for
joining us as always they shoot nè we
look forward to hanging out to you next
week
Mary okay bye but she's busy spoilers
there's me I can't shoot anything they
know it's the end of the episode what
are you doing